[موسيقى]
يترقب العسكريون في الولايات المتحده خلال
الاشهر القليله المقبله مصير التجارب على
طائره الهليكوبتر المستقبليه للجيش
الامريكيه هذه الطائره التي تعمل عليها
اكبر شركه لطائرات في الولايات المتحده
التي من المقرر حل محل طائره البلاك هوك
مع حلول عام 2005
لتنفيذ مهام هجوميه بعيده المدى للجيش
الامريكي
هذه المراوح ستمنحها قدره كبيره على
المناوره والطيران في اتجاهات مختلفه
وايضا بزوايا ضيقه يتوقع ان تكون اسرع من
طائره البلاك هوك بسرعه تتجاوز 2002
واربعين عقده من دون حموله و100 عقده وهي
بحمولتها القصوى
هذه الطائره ايضا ستكون قادره على قطع
ضعفي المسافه التي تقطعها طائرات البلاك
هوك بمقدار يصل الى 700 ميل من دون الحاجه
لتزود بالوقود في الجو كما ان شركه
الامريكيه ستقوم بتزويد هذه المروحيه
باجهزه الرادار ومنظومات الاستشعار
والمقاعد
[موسيقى]